- Happy November, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
I actually just shared
our 100th Data Science Hangout
recording to YouTube yesterday and
made me realize that we
never actually celebrated that.
So thank you all for being
here and making this
space what it is.
I can't believe we're
already over 100
Data Science Hangouts.
If this is your first time
joining us, hi, so nice to meet
you. I'm Rachael. I lead
customer marketing at Posit.
This is our open space
chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
and you want to join us live,
you can use the link below
to add it to your calendar.
But at the Hangout,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody. Love
to hear from everyone,
no matter your years
of experience, your titles,
industry, or even the
languages that you work in.
It's totally OK to just listen
in here. And I say if you're
out walking the dog
maybe, you're at lunch,
it's OK to just listen in.
But there's also three ways to
jump in and ask questions or
add your own perspective. So
you can raise your hand on
Zoom, and I'll keep
an eye out here.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And just put a little star next
to it if it's something you
want me to read out loud
and said. And then lastly, we have
a Slido link where you can
ask questions anonymously too.
And thank you, Curtis, for
sharing that there in the chat.
Sometimes I forget to say this,
but if anybody is hiring, feel
free to share any open
roles in the chat as well.
That's definitely not
spammy at all to me.
I think it's great to share
those jobs in the chat too.
But with that,
I am so excited to introduce
my co-host for today David Sluder.
David is data science senior
program manager at the
Institute of Nuclear Power
Operations. And, David,
I'd love to have you just
introduce yourself a bit and
share a little bit about
your role but also something you
like to do outside of work too.
- Sure.
Thank you, Rachel. And good
morning, good afternoon,
good evening, depending
on where you are.
I'm really excited to be here.
I've got two disclaimers though I
have to start off with, right?
So number one, I just
want to publicly say,
I'm here to represent
my own opinion.
I am not here to
represent my employer,
Institute of Nuclear
Power Operations,
or the broader nuclear
industry. You know, of course,
I'm going to talk about them
to give the conversation some
context. But this is
purely my opinion.
And then the second piece is
that I really need to make sure
everyone knows that anything
I talk about today is--
it's not just my work. So I
work as part of a broader team.
And the team has worked so
hard to build out data science at
INPO. I work with a bunch
of smart passionate people.
And it's just really
important that they get
a lot of credit too here.
So with that said,
my name is David Sluder. I'm
a data scientist here at INPO.
I've been at INPO for almost
12 years now, only about 2 years
in the data science space,
about 10 years in the
IT space here at INPO.
And
it's
a really interesting company.
And I didn't know anything about
INPO until I started to work here.
So maybe I'll give you a
briefer on what we are and what
we do. So INPO is an
independent non-profit that
is funded by our members.
And our members are the
nuclear power industry.
So within the US, I think
we have 54 nuclear power stations.
And they all kind of pay
us a member based fee
to perform our service.
And now our service is that we
set and assess safety and
reliability standards for the
nuclear power industry. So we
set these standards. We send
out evaluation teams to
actually kind of determine how
well the different stations are
adhering to these standards. We
kind of give them a score
at the very end of that.
And we do that on
a regular cadence.
So we do that along with
also kind of facilitating the
sharing of knowledge
across stations,
which is really interesting
in an industry where you have
different companies
competing together,
but then also sharing
information with an independent
organization that
allows them to share
what they've learned so that
we're all able to learn from
each other's experiences,
mistakes, challenges,
that sort of thing.
I've been doing kind of data
science for about two years now.
Before that, I worked on IT.
But my background
is my bachelor's.
You can call it my
background is in humanistic psychology
which is the most qualitative
thing that you could do.
So it's been a fun road
to figure out how I got here.
Outside of work, I like
to do a lot of things.
I like to read. I like to
laugh. And I like to travel.
So this past weekend, I was
able to indulge in all three.
You know, Posit Con for
this year was in Chicago.
And it was the first time I
had been to Chicago with any chance
to explore it. So I got back
home, and I told my wife,
Katie, hey, we need
to go to Chicago.
So we went to Chicago
this past weekend.
And we saw our
favorite comedian.
We went to go see some improv.
We found kind of
a punk bookstore,
which was a whole lot of fun.
And we got to do just a lot
of wandering around the city.
So it was an awesome trip.
And I, at this point,
kind recommend
Chicago to anyone,
especially if it's the
weekend before Halloween because then
you just get to ride around
on the L train and watch
everyone's costumes.
- That's awesome.
I know there were a few people
from Posit who have been
thinking about moving there after
going for Posit Conference too.
- I see why. Yeah.
- I see George asked,
who did you see perform?
- Maria Bamford. She's
my favorite comedian.
Number two is Kyle Cunane.
- Well, David,
thanks so much for the intro
and sharing a little bit about
your background there. I know,
when we were chatting you
shared some more info on how
you had previously worked in
IT as well. And so I was just
curious to kick off the
conversation with that because
that's something that comes
up quite a bit in this space.
But having moved from IT to
data science, I know you have
probably pretty unique
perspectives on both sides.
What would you recommend
to some of us who might be
struggling to communicate
across those lines?
- That's a good question.
And I think a challenge that
I hear in the Hangouts and then
also just kind of conversations
I've had with other people.
To
me, a lot of times, you
have these challenges.
And it really just kind of
boils down to building a good
relationship.
So that can
pan out in a lot
of different ways.
And it's really dependent
on your organization.
And I think how it's set up and
just kind of the general size of it.
The way that we did it was
we
kind of built data science
not quite from scratch.
But we had one organization at INPO
that did some sort of data science-y work.
And then our senior leadership team
kind of identified it as a
strategic priority for the
company to actually build out
that capability.
So then there was a lot of
emphasis and a lot of focus on
it. And that was right after
I had moved into the data science
organization. So we
knew that data science and
IT needed to work together
because, I mean,
every single project that we work
on has an IT component to
it. So
some of what we did is
we started having
leadership meetings between data
science leadership and IT
leadership on some sort of
regular cadence just to talk about
what the roadmaps look like,
what projects are on the
horizon, what challenges
there might be,
and just kind of putting
everything out in the open as
much as you can just to
have those conversations.
On a more
personal level,
I think it's really important
for the two groups to learn
more about what
each group does.
So sit down with a
network engineer and understand why
they might be a little cautious
about opening up all of--
opening
up their infrastructure to all of
the packages on a repo or having
a network engineer,
sit down with a data
scientist and understand why that's a
challenge for them.
It really, to me, just
comes down to having conversations
and being open, and honest,
and transparent, and figuring out a
way to move forward together.
- That's great.
How did you actually
first start those conversations?
I think you said it was at
the Sr. Leadership level.
But was there something that
kind of drove those initial
conversations?
- Well, so
data science kind of became
an emphasis for INPO because the
way that we were doing
business was changing. So we
go and evaluate stations
every two years.
That's kind of been the regular
cadence for about 30 years.
But a lot can happen in between
those two-year assessments,
right? So we understood that we
needed to get into more of a
continuous monitoring
sort of fashion.
And the only way that we can
do that because we don't want to
go out and evaluate more often,
it's a really costly thing to
set up an evaluation team and
send it to a
station. So instead,
it meant that we needed to
figure out a way to use the
data that we have to do some
modeling, some analysis,
and try to understand what
their quote-unquote performance
looks like in between
those evaluations.
So that was kind of where
it landed at a strategic level.
And then it kind of became
our job to actually
implement that. And
recently,
it was real lucky having moved
right from IT to data science
and being able to bring
that perspective to both sides,
I think, put us in a
really good situation.
But I know that's kind of
a rare situation to be in too.
So I think,
yeah, just kind of
like sitting down,
putting your chairs in
a circle, and saying, what's
going on? What can we work on?
How do we figure this
all out together?
Is just kind of the way
the right way to start.
- Yeah. Thank you.
Russ, I see you asked
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah. Thank you.
I have a master's in
counseling I love humanistic psychology.
I could talk to you
about that all day.
How does that help you
in data science? If so,
can you say
something about that?
- I thought about that kind
of in preparation for that talk.
And the more that
I thought about it,
the more kind of threads
that I could see.
Just because a lot of data
science and a lot of working in
an organization in general
is kind of working on
relationships and
communication. And
actually, actively
listening, that was something I
remember taking a class on that
when I was in college.
And I feel like I still
try to use those skills to
this day where you're actually
sitting there in front of a
person and you're hearing what they say,
and you're thinking about what
they say instead of figuring
out what you're just
going to say next.
So kind of having a
real active listening sort of conversation,
and then understanding
that people
are people, and we can
be inconsistent and hard to
understand, and really
all it takes is maybe a
little bit of openness and kindness to
give space to the sorts
of conversations that need to happen,
the sorts of crucial
conversations that we have--
we call it,
that's kind of a term that we
use at INPO for these sort of
intense conversations that need
some sort of resolution. And
in my opinion,
just kind of being open
to that and understanding that there's
going to be some
emotional reactions.
And that's a-OK because
we're all human beings.
But it's important to not just kind of
react to them and just fan the flames.
You need to figure out what the
sources of the issue and address that.
- Love that. Thank you. Alan,
I see you have a question here.
You want to jump in?
- Yeah, sure. Hey.
Hey, David. I'm really curious,
so my instinct is that
performance metrics in nuclear
power is really, really specific,
like a super specific domain.
If that's the case,
I wonder how that domain
expertise comes to play in the
stuff you do day to day or
if maybe that's the wrong
assumption and really
the metrics are around
efficiency, and people metrics,
and things that are
really familiar.
Like I wonder how specific
what you're doing is to
that industry and
how you operate in that
kind of environment?
- That's an excellent question.
So the industry metrics we get,
we get hundreds of data points
from every station every month. And
we use that to--
we end up--
because every station can
be a little different.
You've got to go through
some sort of normalization scheme.
So we have these
indicators that are a way--
that we normalize the data.
And then that's what we
can actually do some modeling on.
And I have learned just
how little I know about nuclear
power by moving to the industry
side of things and needing to
understand exactly what every
label, every acronym means.
And it will take a really long
time to get to that point.
And luckily, I don't need all of
that to do my day to day job.
But whenever I'm working on
a really important model,
I've got to make sure that
I'm not making some really bad
assumptions about it.
So that means that I got to
sit down and talk with my manager, director,
or some other subject matter
experts in some of the
functional areas here at
INPO just to kind of make
sure that
whatever I don't know isn't
going to actually bite me
sometime. So yeah,
that's a great comment.
- Thanks. I know you mentioned
data science is relatively
new for INPO.
How have you been successful
in introducing data science and
data science tools?
- Great question. So
introducing
a new tool to the enterprise
is a really challenging thing.
You can't just say here
are some model results and expect
everyone to understand what that
means. So one of the
changes that we've made.
And it's actually kind of
part of our governance that we've
written is that anytime there
is a new tool of some sort
delivered, we have to
figure out a way to
explain it or interpret it
with some
other tool or maybe kind of
a help function of some sort.
So one of the things that
we've learned is that
delivering these model results
that require some
subtlety and understanding
is hard to do for people that
don't use it on a
real frequent basis.
So we've added a lot more
kind of like help functions into the
tools that we build the
way that we expose these model
results. And then we've also,
of built some other tools to--
I got to talk generally,
to help you understand why
the model is saying what it's
saying. And we've had
a lot of success in
thinking about things from
the end user perspective and
not at the data science perspective
to help us figure out exactly
what we can do better to
make sure that they use the
tool correctly and they get the
insight that they
want out of it.
- Yes.
Kind of maybe this follows
along with this a little bit
and no worries if there's
certain things you can't share
with us. But there was an
anonymous question that was,
what kind of data science use
cases can you share with us in
the nuclear industry
and in your company?
- Yeah. So
one I kind of alluded to
earlier is kind of the impetus
for data science at INPO
is trying to understand
performance in between the
assessments every two
years, biannual, biennial,
I never remember the word.
So we get data
from the industry every month.
And we have a model that
helps us gauge that sort of
performance in between
the assessments.
So the assessments are kind of
our gold standard and the way
that we know if the
model is right or wrong.
But it gives us an
estimate in between for their performance.
And then from there,
there are other things where you
can maybe kind of come up
with some risk models to
see if something has a high
probability of happening.
And
obviously, you don't want
it to happen. So we want to
figure out that risk and
try to get ahead of it.
Let's see what else we got.
I'm going to stop there just
to make sure I keep it
general enough, sorry.
- That's OK. So when
you share those models, who
are you sharing them with or
how do you share the model with
broader stakeholder groups?
So data science at INPO,
our department is actually
called data science.
And it's composed of three
groups. So one is data
visualization. One is
kind of data analytics.
And that's where I live.
And then one is data quality
or data management. I think
we call it data quality.
So whenever I build a model,
I'm just kind of having the
results end up in a database
somewhere. And then we rely
on our incredibly capable data
visualization group to
actually kind of build those
visualizations to deliver
it to an end user.
So no one ever really gets
those raw results out of the database.
They get something within a
broader context to help them--
to help make sure that they
are interpreting it correctly.
- Thank you.
- Sure.
- Let me jump over to one other
anonymous question
first here. And one was,
pharma has a huge emphasis on
a very muddled concept of validation.
Is there something like this
perception of regulatory
overhead that
affects your work?
- That exists within
the nuclear industry.
But it doesn't affect INPO. So
there is--
I remember when I worked
IT, there's a group,
it's called NITSL, N-I-T-S-L.
The Nuclear Information
Technology and Strategic
Leadership group, which is kind of
a more nuclear IT group, working group.
And they have a focus on
quality assurance because there
are very strict
regulations that go into
how you validate that a system,
that like a software system is going to
do what you say it's going to do
as long as it--
it's going to do what
you say it's going to do,
and it's going to
work correctly,
and there's no way that it
can kind of get it wrong.
But that mostly affects the
safety systems at nuclear stations.
As far as I understand--
this is obviously
not my wheelhouse.
But because we at INPO
don't work directly with
supporting the safety system
at a nuclear power station,
we don't really have to
go through that very,
very rigorous process.
- Thank you. George,
I think this question
might be kind of related.
But I saw you had a question
earlier about safety assessments. Do
you want to jump in?
- Sure. Yeah. Yeah,
I was just curious,
the data that you're producing
and from the assessments,
is that ever shared with
other federal agencies?
And I was thinking of OSHA and
just been thinking more about
how similar to the Nordisk and
their submissions to the FDA?
I'm wondering if you're doing something
like that or if it's even possible.
- We do
share some of the
content from the reports.
Let me make sure that--
I know the one
place that we share
the
report, I believe,
it's the report but
it's definitely the assessment
number, the assessment
score is the company that
issues out insurance to
the nuclear power industry. So
our assessment score
is directly linked to
nuclear stations
insurance rate,
which gives us a
little bit of--
it makes it very important that
everything is right and that there are
kind of no worries, no challenges
to it that can't be answered.
We share some,
we call it, operating
experience with
some other groups.
But I don't think that we
share the actual report with them.
So it's a very tightly
guarded thing that we share
with the senior leadership at a
station. And
we share at least the
assessment number with the
insurance group. But
for the most part,
we kind of hold on to the
actual report findings
because there's
a lot of ways that
sharing that can go wrong.
Sorry, not a great answer.
- David,
I feel like this might be a
helpful conversation to open up with the group.
But I know when you and
I were chatting at Posit Conference,
we were talking a bit about
how when you rolled out Posit Team,
it would have been helpful to
know what a bit more about what
some other teams were doing
with the products as well to
also kind of get ideas and
share use cases with each other.
I don't know if you want
to expand on that a bit.
And maybe ask to the group too.
- Yeah. Heck, yeah.
So this is kind of my
question for the group is we
recently rolled out Posit Team.
And the
modeling work that we've
done at INPO has been a very
particular kind of modeling work
where you kind of build a
big model and you
deliver some results,
and then it gets sent
to a visualization, and that's
mostly it. But I know that
there is a lot more that
Posit
Team and other platforms offer
a lot more capabilities than
that rather than just building a
model and putting results in a database
and kind of coming relatively
new into this space,
it's been hard to just kind
figure out what are the different
ways to use it. Like, what
are the things that I don't first
and then what are maybe
the best ways to solve certain
problems that I do know about.
So at a real technical
level, we have
a lot of Microsoft SQL servers,
and trying to use those with
Posit has some challenges.
So what are the best
ways to solve that?
I know that Posit has a lot
of really good documentation
online. But I'd
love to hear from
people that have actually
solved this problem and kind of
learn what they've learned in
the process, if that makes sense.
So where would someone go
to kind of learn these best
practices or have this sort
of conversation outside of a
weekly Data Science Hangout?
- Yeah, I see Javier you
put some thoughts in the chat.
Do you want to
get us going here?
- I'm like mid chew with
my breakfast. Sorry.
- I'm sorry.
But I'll comment in a bit here.
- OK.
Who else wants to jump in then?
- One of the things we
had a lot of success with
in a former life of mine
was when we deployed reports and a
lot of these reports were
sort of meant to monitor
model scores over time. And so
this is not helping your
Microsoft issue, I'm sorry. But
in terms of just
use cases in general,
we would do things like
query in the back end, we could
run a report every day, every week
perform a query,
bring in this new data
that we hadn't seen yet,
and then run that through
our models, and then
get some model scores.
And then we could track those
model scores compared to
yesterday's, last
week's, whatever it is,
and then we could use
Blastula to send out alerts.
And we could essentially create
a custom report based on what
we were seeing, and that
could be sent out to
certain
individuals associated with
the account in question,
and that sort of thing. So
it was a nice handy monitoring tool.
- Thanks.
- I'm not I'm not
chewing anymore.
- OK.
- I could pop back in. But
yeah, David, I don't know
if you're using dbplyr.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. OK, so you
know about that.
That's something we're--
I'm surprised how many users at
my company don't know of dbplyr.
And so they're like
creating SQL files or
they're just doing
things maybe in like a
2010 view of the world.
And that's OK because a lot
of them are more like proper
statisticians who DevOps and
MLOps isn't really something
in their wheelhouse.
Are you using--
well, I assume you're
using some kind of
like Git-backed platform
like GitHub or GitLab.
Something we've recently been
exploring with Posit Connect
is just setting up a lot of
CI/CD pipelines to sort of
make the whole
deployment of
content across different
maybe, like, Connect instances.
So if you've got different
like dev or test or production
instances, we're
trying to create
a process of
being hands off
like rolling up everything
through a lot of CI/CD.
And Posit has like
excellent documentation on this stuff.
So if you're not doing that,
I definitely recommend
something like that too.
And it plays nicely with dbplyr also.
- I guess kind of even
at a higher level,
so we have this platform, this
weekly hangout that we could
use to ask questions if it's
the right context. But like,
where do you all go
outside of this to
learn about
the right ways to do things?
Or people's experiences way with
different ways to do things?
- Yeah. For me, personally,
I feel like I'm asking
questions all the time in public
places, internally at least.
I mean, I say public. Like,
we have so many teams
channels around data, and data quality,
and data science, and
analytics, and all this stuff.
Like,
I'm pretty shameless when it
comes to asking a bunch of
questions on these things.
At the same time, like,
I feel like I'm constantly
helping other people. So it's
like, there's
give and take. But
I think, for me,
it's a lot of just
on-the-job
exposure and experience,
asking people stuff
that maybe I wouldn't
be able to ask publicly
and just like
working together to
get
through some of these hurdles.
I mean, every team has
really unique challenges.
They might be using
AR. But they're like--
they're trying to map to
some network drive or something.
And it's like, well, we can't
really do that or not as
easily. But they want
to fix. So it's like--
I don't know. Sorry,
I feel like I'm hijacking
the conversation here.
- I like what you're
saying. But like, internal networking,
I guess, is what
I would summarize my comments.
That's really
helped a lot for us.
And I think Catherine from
my company is on here too.
I don't know if she has
any additional comments.
- Yeah.
Javier is totally shameless
about asking tons of questions.
And sure thing. But I do
think that you're right in asking about
where do you go to get
best practices because,
internally, your team has--
or your company has a
way that they do things.
So getting exposure to the
ways that other companies do things,
like, knowing what else is
out there can be really difficult.
I don't personally do too much
research because I try to not
work outside of work.
But it does make it--
it does make it difficult to
figure out what else is out
there to then come back to
those conversations if you're
setting up data scientists
to IT or those kinds of
conversations to bring those ideas if
you don't know what they are.
- Yeah. I don't know
what I don't know.
- Yeah.
And I know some industry groups
like pharma have their own, like,
AR in pharma organizations as well
to share things with each other. But
I think a great
option too is like meeting
each other from within this group
too and having like
smaller conversations or one-off conversations.
I know some people have gotten
to make friends from the Data
Science Hangouts too.
So I encourage people to
connect with each other on
LinkedIn too and feel
free to share your
LinkedIns in the chat too if
you do want to connect with others.
But I feel like I should
say this here too.
Something I've been thinking about
is if there are certain
topics that come up in a
forum like this where we maybe want
to dive deeper into it,
could we have a smaller group
conversation following it.
Maybe it's on a specific
topic, like, I don't know
securing
packages or having the
conversation with it about
using open source packages
or maybe it's about shiny in
production or
something like that.
So
I'll think a bit
more on that as well.
- Yeah. The challenge
for us is, we,
at INPO, are
pretty new to this.
So there isn't that sort
of institutional knowledge that we can
reach out and question
other people about it. So
at this point, either
kind of talking to other
people in the nuclear industry.
And we do have
a data science industry working group
that we've set up at INPO
but across the
nuclear industry.
And we're starting to get
some good traction with that.
But even past that, it's
good to have conversations with people
in different industries
just to understand
how they might think
about things differently.
- Absolutely.
Justin, I see you had a
question a bit earlier. Justin
Lee, do you want to jump in?
- Yes, I am looking back to
see what my question was.
- No worries.
I can ask your question if
you want to add context too. But--
- Please do.
- The question was,
speaking generally,
how is the industry beginning
to use natural language processing?
- OK.
I'll tell you the
little that I know. So
I know that
some places have set up
their own private instances of ChatGPT
because nuclear
data is regulated, tightly regulated.
So you have to be
really careful about what
infrastructure it lives on.
So generally speaking,
we're going to want to keep
things on premise in our own
domains rather than use something on
Azure or AWS if we can.
So people have set up
private instances of ChatGPT
to try to understand how
it could be used for
their organizations.
And there has been some success
but. As you all probably know,
not everything that comes
out of ChatGPT is correct,
even if it sounds like a
good well-formed sentence.
So there's that. And then a
lot there's a lot
of interest in
trying to figure out how to
look at--
this is a pretty well known
kind of program across
stations. So I don't think
it's wrong to talk about it.
So stations have something
called a corrective action
program. So
kind of generally
speaking, anytime
there is an event,
something goes wrong,
whether that's someone
tripping on the sidewalk,
walking into the station, or
there's a reactor scram, there is
a report written up about that.
And for
a single unit station,
I think there's probably 600
people working there. And
that means there are a lot
of these reports that get written.
And at
a certain point,
you have a whole lot of
text data and not enough people or
the right technology to
actually kind of trend it and
track it well. So there's a
lot of interest right now in
understanding how to use this
kind of history of cap records
to understand the
behaviors that might
influence performance.
So those are the two kind of
big use cases I've heard so far.
- That makes sense. Thank you.
- Thank you.
Another
question, I think I maybe saw
earlier maybe something
anonymous as well.
Well, actually, let me
shift gears for a second.
I know when we were
chatting before,
you were talking a little bit
about how you're hiring for a role.
And I thought it might be good
to just discuss a little bit of
what you've learned recently in trying
to fill a data science role too?
- It is--
it's challenging, as a
lot of you probably know.
So we did actually
fill the role.
The person hasn't started yet.
But kind of everything's been signed.
So we're good there.
And I feel like I learned a
lot about what it takes to hire a
data scientist in that process.
So
we found that we got
a lot of success using
recruiters versus just kind of
having an open job posting just
because the market is
pretty well flooded.
And we wanted someone that
had some particular natural language
experience.
So instead of going through the
mountain of resumes,
it was a little bit easier
to have people help us find--
people who were looking and people
who had the right sort of resume.
And then from there,
going through the technical screen to
make sure that they had the
right understanding that
we were looking for.
And then so that wasn't
too bad. But trying
to find the right--
especially when
I don't know enough about
natural language processing to
put it on my resume.
But I'm trying to hire people
who have that experience. You know,
you've got to do enough
research so that you can ask
the right questions. And it
was pretty interesting.
It was a lot of fun,
to be honest with you.
But it was surprising to
figure out exactly, in the process,
what you needed to look for on
a resume to get the right level
of experience because
having some space-y
or some hugging face
experience doesn't necessarily mean that
you were right
for the role. And
the thing that I think
surprised me most was that when
we started looking for people
who didn't just have a master's
degree in data science or
analytics but were looking for
things that were kind of more,
like, applied roles
where you were getting
a master's in or a
PhD in something besides those
particular fields. But you
had to use machine learning,
data science, NLP
in order to actually
achieve that PhD
or that master's.
There was a lot of--
I found those conversations
to be surprisingly useful because
this person is not just--
I went through
a master's program and got
a master's in analytics. And for
the capstone, it was like, OK,
you get to figure out how
to put all of this together,
and then do it on your
own and figure it out.
You took all these classes
and you get to figure it out.
And people with kind of,
what I'm calling an
applied perspective for data science
have already been able to
do that. And it's just--
it was really useful to suss
that out in the process. So
that's something I'd
recommend is maybe expanding
the pool of applicants past
just those people that have the
master's degrees in analytics and
data science that I think
we probably all have seen
them or have those ourselves.
- Yeah.
So did you end up redesigning
the job description a bit?
- No. We
just ended up
taking a while to find
the right candidate.
- Ben, I see you just put
a question in the chat.
Want to jump in?
- Yeah. Hey, David.
Thanks for the time.
What are you currently working
on to build your skill set?
I'm thinking more on
the technical side. Obviously,
you're doing a lot
on the soft skills.
But what are some
maybe historical
stuff that has been in
your industry or some other things
outside of your industry that
you're working on that's going
to advance your skill set
do you find interesting maybe?
- So
I got to learn about--
I got to learn a lot about
Linux, it's a tongue twister,
because I was the one that
got to do the Posit install earlier
this year. So that was
interesting, challenging.
I know a lot more about
infrastructure than I ever did now.
And I'll file that
away for a rainy day.
On the data science
side of things, I am--
where's my book?
I'm reading through Max's
book Applied Predictive Modeling, right?
And just trying to of
wrap my head around
things dealing--
the different sorts of models
and approaches to maybe kind of
cross-validation,
statistical machine learning that
we'll need because we tend
to use smaller data
sets at INPO. So we
don't have anything that I would
call big data at the moment.
So it's a very particular kind
of flavor of data science and
machine learning. So
I'm reading through that and
then just trying to figure out
different ways to actually stay up
to date with new models, new algorithms,
finding the right papers to read
to stay up to date with
those sorts of advances.
And I haven't really found
a great place that kind of
centralizes all that
information yet.
So if anybody else has
some ideas about where to look,
I think I learned about our
weekly at Posit Conf this year. So
yeah,
feel free to share that because
I've got an appetite for it.
- I was just saying,
I see a lot of great links
shared in the chat too.
So I'll take those,
and consolidate them,
and share with you
as well, David.
- Thank you. That's excellent.
-
An anonymous question from a
bit earlier was what are the
biggest challenges you face
when putting data science
solutions in production?
- So
I mean, to be honest,
we haven't faced a whole lot
of that yet because we are still
pretty fresh. My
brain goes back
to the way that we
created
a model that kind of estimates
performance in between
evaluations and
deliver those results. But
because that model is such
a kind of a tightly guarded
secret, I
consider it probably the
most critical piece of intellectual
property we have at INPO
because if anyone finds out
what goes into that model, then
there's no way to
build a better model.
So
delivering those results meant that
we can't tell people what
goes into the model,
which means that when
a station's value changes,
they of course,
want to know why.
That's just a
natural thing to ask.
And we
didn't really give people a great
way to explain that at a
kind of a general level. So
last year,
we built a tool to help
them kind of interpret that score
and the changes to that score.
And every time we would build
this model, we'd get this
mountain of emails asking
why this and that changed.
And then we built this tool
that helps give context to the
changes. And, you know,
now it's kind of crickets
every time we publish the model
results, which is good
news for everyone.
Past that, we're going to
be building more kind of tools,
models, APIs.
But we haven't done it yet.
So I'm not really sure what
the challenges are, right?
So if anyone has
any lessons learned,
I'm so ready and willing to hear
what you all have learned as part pushing
out Posit Team or any
other sort of data science platform.
- Yeah. And, David,
if people do want to
connect directly after,
is LinkedIn the best way?
- Yeah. Yeah. OK,
I'll share your LinkedIn chat
here in a second too. But,
Nick, I see you just asked
a question in the chat.
Want to jump in here next?
- Oh. Yeah, sure. Hi,
everyone. So basically,
I'm trying to relate to
something I'm currently going
through at work where we just
set up an analytics team.
And before the business is
willing to really commit any
resources and invest,
we keep getting this
ask to estimate the ROI we
expect from the project before
the business is willing to
commit any time or resources to
help us with it. And basically,
I'd like to ask you for
idea around how do you
approach estimating the ROI from
a project before you even
really have the resources
or the buy in to start
looking into it? And
follow-up question,
once a project is implemented,
how do you look back and
estimate the ROI from a project
you've implemented already?
-
So this is a really challenging
question to ask because we are
a nonprofit with a mission to make
sure that the industry performs
at the highest standards of
excellence that we can set.
So coming up with an ROI,
it's really hard to quantify that.
And we have different
ways that we do that.
But I don't really maybe
think that they're more generally
applicable to what
you're talking about
from a pure project
management standpoint.
Ideally, I feel like what
you would want to do is
put together--
I was going to try
to answer it well.
But I don't have a good answer
for you. Yeah, it's just--
it's not something
that we deal with
in the same way that
I think that you do.
And I don't feel like I've
got a good answer for you.
- I could share one from--
I could share one from another
hangout we had with Natalie O'Shea
at BetterUp.
I was trying to find the little
clip to share with you. But
Natalie shared a bit how when
she was going through this
process for getting
approval for Posit Team, she
focused in on one specific problem
that the team had. And so
the use case she gave was they're
a consulting
organization, so their
sales team had to make
these PowerPoints over and over again
with new data and based
on different industries.
And to actually make a
great deck for a presentation was
taking hours and hours.
And so
they sent out a poll to all
of the sales reps to ask how much
time were they taking
building these.
And they actually put a dollar
amount to it. And so I think
it ended up being like $1.2
million a year in people cost.
And then she showed how
she could automate that with a
Shiny application that the sales
team would go to the
Shiny app and put in
whatever they needed for the customer,
and then automatically
generate the PowerPoint,
which was tied directly
to their database as well.
And using that one example,
she was able to put a
dollar amount to it. So maybe that's
one tip is to think
when you're building this
business case to think about
one team that you might be
able to help because then they might
be the ones kind of joining
on to your business case too.
I think it was maybe the
head of sales that ended up helping
push it forward for
their data team too.
- I think that's a very useful
insight actually, Rachel.
Thanks for that. Only thing is
that I think when it comes to
automation of
daily routine tasks
and activities, it's
a bit easier to estimate
ROI as opposed to analytics
modeling where you're dealing
with uncertainty, right?
And sometimes you're not even
sure if you'll get anywhere
with the time you
invest, right? So
yeah, it's not an easy task.
And I would really appreciate
any thoughts or feedback from
anyone that's gone through that
experience before as well. Cheers.
- Nick, this is
Eduardo Castillo.
And I actually am from the
nuclear industry. I know, Dave,
we are working group at INPO.
And one thing I can offer from
a data science perspective is
that it's important to kind of
go for big targets.
So one of the big projects
we're working on right now is around
reducing diving frequencies
for cleaning some of our intake
structures. And that's a very
big $1 million a year project
where we had no ongoing
data science efforts to improve
performance of that
evolution. And so having
a big target. I think,
was important because
even if we could cut 5%
of that, it becomes
a good hard dollar--
dollar ROI. And
the second piece is
looking at things
like risk. Like,
when you have an
activity like diving,
you do have a
lot of occupational risk.
And we're actually
able to tie what
the occupational risk is
and how it compares to other
activities that we
do at the plant.
So it allows us to kind of
capture both the hard savings
and also the qualitative
softer savings. And again,
just starting with a big
target of project that
is targeting a big budget,
I think, it's important.
- Thanks, Eduardo.
- Yeah. Thank you so much.
Anybody else want to
jump in on this topic?
Laura, I see you unmuted.
Do you want to add something?
- Yeah. I can't
find the button.
Yeah, I just want to--
for the idea about ROI,
there's a podcast called
CDO Matters by a guy Malcolm
Hawker. He works at Profisee
with doing MDM.
And he's got--
listen to his podcast
while running.
It's a great like
intellectual thing.
It has a lot of
information about ROI,
especially in light of-- you
see see a lot of these press
releases about data teams
being laid off. And those
of us in data are like,
how can you do that?
Data is so important.
But again,
it's that proof that
you're actually impacting the bottom
line of the company.
And so if you want to
dig a little more into that world,
I highly recommend
his podcasts.
They're not--
they're not too overly
fluffy with crap.
And they're all quite
interesting about 45 minutes.
So I highly recommend if that
idea of ROI is important.
- Absolutely. Yeah,
I think you shared the
link maybe in the chat too.
OK.
- Thanks
for the recommendation.
- Abigail, do you want
to add anything here?
I saw your comment
in the chat too.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah,
feel free to just raise your
hand on here if anybody has
anything else to add,
but I'll try and jump over
to some of the remaining questions too.
Let's see. We had quite a few
anonymous questions.
I want to make sure I
didn't miss anything.
But when we get to the
last few minutes here,
if there's something you ask
that didn't get answered as
well, feel free to recopy
it into the Zoom chat here.
But one of the other questions,
David, was,
what is your company's
relationship as relates to the
interface between
government and industry?
- So
that's great.
So there's the NRC which
is kind of the government
regulator. And they have
all of their own guidelines.
They do their own
sorts of evaluations.
But the
whole
impetus of INFO was when Three
Mile Island happened, there was this--
Jimmy Carter put
together this commission,
it was called the
Kemeny Commission. And
the commission had a
whole lot of findings.
One of them was that there
needed to be kind of an
independent non-governmental organization
to set these sorts
of safety and reliability standards,
and then to assess them.
So we are not really--
I mean, we're in the nuclear
industry. So of course,
we're associated with the NRC.
But we don't really
answer to them.
We kind of answer more
so to our members,
to the domestic
nuclear industry.
So we're two regulatory
bodies that have maybe some
overlapping interests but also
some kind of
different missions.
- Thank you.
And so a question that I love to
get to ask everybody towards the end is
there a piece of career advice
that stands out to you, whether
it's been something that you've
received or advice you've given
that you'd like
to share with us?
- I know you were
going to ask this.
So I had to think
about it in advance.
And I had like five or six
different things that I came up with.
The one that I think I want
to stick with is be open to doing
things that make you
feel uncomfortable.
So as a human being but
also professionally,
that's kind of where
the growth happens.
If you just do the same
thing day in and day out,
you're just going
to kind of Tread
water in a way.
But if you lean into the
things that make you uncomfortable in
a healthy way, obviously,
then I think that's
where you can grow your
professional relationships, your
technical capabilities, like,
your mental health in a way
is kind of leaning into that and
being OK with the discomfort,
knowing that you're going
to learn something from it.
- So can you share an
example with us of where
you're doing that?
- Being asked to do a
Data Science Hangout?
- Yes.
Awesome.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And the other piece.
And I've been a part
of them for seven years
is Toastmasters.
Working on your communication skills
is critical as a data
scientist. You can
create the coolest
model,
next big app, that
sort of thing.
But if you can't really
communicate it well,
then you're going to have
a hard time getting other people
to understand why
it's so important. So
figuring out ways to kind
of hone those skills are really,
really important just as much in
my opinion as the technical skills.
- Definitely. Yani,
I see you had asked a question
in the chat want to jump in here.
- Oh. Yes.
I listen to some great talk.
I would like the speaker
to share some good books.
Good books you like.
Not maybe
definitely, yeah, I love the
books or the science books,
but any other books you
want to share. I mean,
because some words you
said is so smart and wise.
- That's funny.
I'm looking at my bookshelf to see
what kind of pops into my head.
I'm not
employed by Posit,
but they do--
people that work for Posit
have some pretty good books
for data science. And then also
kind of the
Elements of Statistical Learning.
That was one of the books that
I ended up buying as part of my
graduate program that I
still refer to to this day.
Outside of that,
I picked up a book
called On Being Nice
this past weekend
that I really enjoy
and kind of sits well with me.
And then there's also a
book that started reading called
Focus that's really,
really interesting.
But these are just kind of
things that are off the top of
my head. I can't really
think of anything else
major. But
I'd love for people to maybe
type into the chat any books
that you might recommend,
whether they're related
to data science or not.
I want to see that list.
- I'd like to know.
- Yeah.
Does anybody have Libby's link
handy. She's been keeping track
of all the books
recommended in the Hangout.
- Oh, that's fun.
- Oh, I don't know.
- I'm being a bad multitasker
today, trying to go find it.
So if anybody can share
it, that would be great.
I see--
I see there's a--
Thank you. I see
there's a bit of a
kind of sub-conversation
happening in the chat too when
we were talking about maybe
these smaller group chats too
and perhaps having one like a
whole discussion on ROI
might be a useful one. So
I will save this chat here so
I can reach out to everybody.
But in that thread,
if you want to
just put your email
in there,
I'll say it right here,
I will save that and reach
out so we can maybe schedule a
separate chat around ROI too.
Awesome. So let's see.
For any questions that
have gone unanswered,
does anybody want to raise your
hand here and jump in and ask
it? I think we have--
I think we've covered most
everything. Oh, Michael. There you go.
- So I want to see if
I can still access the
information in the chat because
I do not want to lose them.
I've missed some. So I still
want to get back to them.
- Yes, yes. Definitely.
So if you want to save
the info in the chat,
you can use the three dots
below it where it says more.
And then you can
press Save Chat there.
But, David, guess,
to end on a note of--
- I don't know. I
think the function--
- If you want to--
Michael, if you want to
share your email in the chat, I
can email it to you as well,
if it doesn't work for you. But, David,
one other question I'd love to
ask is thinking about the year ahead
of 2024,
what's something that you're
excited about for your team.
-
This year was kind of focused
on building out what we call
our data science environment,
getting Posit built.
And now it's built, it's
stable, and we're ready to use
it. And I'm just excited to
try to figure out all
the different ways that we can
deliver these really incredible
data science products to
the industry at large, and
then also to INPO internally.
It's just something
that we've never really had
and really, really excited to
put it to good use.
- Awesome. Well, thank
you so much, David,
for joining us today.
And thank you all for
all the great questions and spending
your Thursday with us.
I'm trying to get better
about saying this.
But I talk to a
lot of people from
companies who might not know
that other teams within their
company are using our tools.
So if you are ever just curious
and want to chat with us about
it, I made a little, like,
form for myself so that it was
in one place. So feel free to
put your name there.
And I'm happy to connect you
with others within your company too.
But thank you again for
spending time with us today.
Really appreciate it, David.
- Thank you for having me.
- Thank you, Rachel. Thank
you, David. Thank you, everyone. Bye-bye.
- Bye, everybody.
Thank you. you.